[Música]
como cabeza de La Poderosa iglesia rusa
ortodoxa tiene un papel crucial en la
sociedad
[Música]
el patriarca de Moscú kiril es el líder
espiritual de 150 millones de fieles en
todo el mundo
pero con la guerra en Ucrania también se
ha convertido en parte de la campaña
nacionalista de Vladimir Putin
la cercanía es Clara en los sermones del
patriarca como este tres días después de
la invasión rusa
estuve un niño
Dios no quiera que la situación política
actual en la fraterna Ucrania tenga como
objetivo hacer que las fuerzas del mal
prevalezcan fuerzas que siempre han
luchado contra la unidad de Rusia y la
iglesia rusa
kiril cuyo verdadero nombre es Vladimir
gundayev fue nombrado decimosexto
patriarca de Moscú en 2009 así comenzó
una estrecha relación con Putin que
continúa una antigua tradición de Rusia
la iglesia subordinada al poder político
como Putin kiril experimentó un ascenso
meteórico ordenado en monje a los 23
años se inició en la diplomacia
religiosa y como espía en la kgb
desde la década de 1970 hasta la década
de 1990 ascendió en las filas de la
iglesia ortodoxa y también hizo una
fortuna en la industria del tabaco
gracias a las licencias otorgadas a la
iglesia por el gobierno
políticamente kiril se alinea con Putin
él también describe un occidente
moralmente deficiente y respalda todos
los proyectos militares del kremlin
muchas veces ha bendecido los tanques
rusos que partían hacia Ucrania y yo
hispania si alguien muere en el
cumplimiento de su deber militar
entonces indudablemente comete un acto
equivalente a un sacrificio y por lo
tanto creemos que esto lava todos los
pecados que una persona ha cometido
sus posiciones provocaron la división
entre las iglesias ortodoxas de Ucrania
y Rusia en 2018
el Papa Francisco quien conoció a kiril
en 2016 lo llamó El Monaguillo de Putin